he has two separate career possum that
his brother and I just think they are
can do a lot more good separated from
the royal family with those constraints
with what their passion is every
astronaut is it tuned to get back to
space that's what we trained so hard for
the next five years in space travel is
going to be incredibly exciting you're
never too young to get a smear I think
because if I had been 25 my story would
have been a really different one
someone told me ten years ago projected
what was going to be happening cases it
was a historic meeting between a divided
family and it was only right the Queen
would deliver the outcomes and this is a
very big seismic moment if you like for
them your family you have these two
people who have been living this life
doing these duties as they have been
done before who was saying actually no
you don't want to do it like this
anymore
we want to do things differently we want
a new model imagine she said she's
supportive of their desire to create a
new life as a family and said there
would be a transition period where Harry
and Megan will split their time between
the UK and Canada well I'm joined now by
Dean start who's been Friends of retired
for 12 years since they served in the
Army together really pleased you could
come in today thanks so much for for
joining us and as we say you've known
Prince Harry for a huge number of years
what did you make of that statement that
he issued it appeared come as a bolt out
of the blue - lots of us who don't know
him but someone who did what did you
make of it when he said he wanted with
his wife to step back from being senior
Royals I first I heard first family
yourself but I wasn't surprised with the
decision you know Harry's his personal
circumstances have changed in the last
two years you know he's now with Megan
he's got a young boy Archie he's always
been vocal in fact that he's wanted a
family well yes and so what is driving
this desire do you think you say in the
last couple of years he's now got a
family is a lot of it about protecting
his family about wanting to focus on his
family what's changed make him want to
make this alteration to his role I think
a bit above you mentioned there about
protecting his family made his statement
last year that you could see history
repeating itself with the world of media
and but him and Megan of their passion
is is tied to it and they want to make
the world a better place so actually
they've already announced that they're
gonna launch a Sussex foundation so very
interesting to see what sort of
charities they focused on there but
again there's less red tape and protocol
for them to be able to do more and do
better good I think well that's right
and he's served in the Armed Forces
alongside you of course he's done a lot
of charity work as well as his royal
duties so his work up until now has been
all about serving his country hasn't it
I mean would you expect his work in the
future to be very much focused on on
Britain and and what he want to retain
some of the elements of it of his royal
duties as he goes ahead yeah he said he
served his country did two tours in
Afghanistan and actually since leaving
the military's done so much for the
military and the veterans you know
Invictus games endeavor fun combat
stress is always that will be one is
focus I think moving forward at better
we split between here and
Canada I don't think he'll turn his back
on his military family it's all they
talked about wanting financial
independence they don't want it says in
the Queen's statement as well they don't
want to be reliant on public funds for
their new lives how do you imagine that
they would raise money how would they
earn their money do you think I think
obviously working in the world of
philanthropy you know sent up their own
foundation away from the rule boundaries
there's more opportunities from the
corporate side for them and Meghan's
come from humble background she's always
worked all their lives so she probably
found it quite difficult you know not
working so it's probably keen to get
back out there how do you think Prince
Harry will be feeling them I think he'll
just want to go go to Canada and spend
some time with Archie and Megan
turbulence well to that report by the
Royal College of Psychiatrists which
wants social media companies to hand
over their data to help protect children
and vulnerable people online
fourteen-year-old Molly Russell took her
own life after viewing unregulated
harmful and violent images on Instagram
Ian joins us now from central London
first of all it's been nearly three
years how are you and your family coping
with the loss I don't think a family
ever really can confined another base
after after a death by suicide of
someone so close in their family it
changes your life forever
but considering that horrible grief that
we've gone through I think we're doing
very well I'm always proud of my wife
and two daughters who we're as a family
unit we all work together we'll support
each other and we all look after each
other and I look to them if I'm feeling
a bit down in a bit weak in a bit sad at
times I look to them and they give me
huge amounts of strength and I know we
all know that Molly wouldn't want if any
of us have felt as we do now in your
mind you're in no doubt that that social
media played a significant part in
Molly's death yes no doubt at all that
social media played a part in in Molly's
death what we found as a family very
easily on Molly's social media accounts
after her death shocked us the sort of
sad bleak content that's available all
to hee
early on everyday platforms such as
Instagram and Pinterest it's just a
horrible world and once you found that
content if you are depressed if you
search for help on the Internet which
we'd like to think Mali might have done
you get connected to these this content
and then the algorithms of the tech
platforms feed you ever more and more of
it and lead you into a very dark place
very quickly self-regulation hasn't
really worked the tech companies still
leave this sort of material online or
they find it hard to remove is what they
say and so something more needs to be
done and a better clarity of
understanding about what why that data
is there and how it affects people is
absolutely vital if we're to save young
lives
so handing over data but anonymize data
so it's all very ethical very safe and
there's no data privacy issues data that
will allow institutions such as the
Royal College of Psychiatrists to to
better understand what's going on and
why there's a rise in self-harm and
suicide in young people if you've been
affected by anything we've discussed
today you can call the Samaritans on
double one six one two three
boosters igniting the engines firing my
seeds from Isaac Newton's apple tree
which were blasted into space for the
astronaut tim peake have successfully
grown and liftoff the Apple pips were
taken to the International Space Station
I spent six months floating in
microgravity now the UK Space Agency is
moved to competition find the space
saplings somewhere to live on earth well
joining me now is the european space
agency astronaut and former
international space station crew member
tim peake item lovely to talk to you
again why were these Apple pips taken
into space well really these Apple pips
are taken into space because what they
represent is you know one of the
greatest scientists Sir Isaac Newton who
was inspired by this apple tree behind
me over three hundred and fifty years
old to come up with his universal laws
of motion and of course his laws of
gravity on which so much of our
knowledge and our understanding to date
has been based so it was a wonderful
opportunity to take some apple seeds
from this original tree into space bring
them back down and they've now grown
into young saplings which are going to
go out to establishments across the UK
to help to inspire and educate our
future generation of new scientists and
engineers at the time that they were in
space and zero gravity doesn't appear to
have had a negative impact at all and
their ability to then germinate no not
at all it'll be very interesting to see
if there will be any longer term effects
and in fact at the same time that apple
seeds were being flown we also flew some
rocket seeds in space and that was part
of a national competition among
schoolchildren as well and we did see
some degradation in those rocket seeds
probably based on the radiation exposure
in space and this is something we're
working towards of course because we
want to go further into space in our
exploration program and being able to
grow our own food in space is very
important and the more that we can
understand about how crops and how seeds
are affected by space travel the more we
can learn for how to prepare for future
missions so where are you hoping that
these trees will go how many saplings
are there and what kind of homes are you
looking for for them so we flew 12 seeds
in
space we've got eight successful
saplings to be given out to
establishments today the obviously it
was it was based on our competition and
these young saplings would be going to
places where they'll continue to inspire
millions of people over the the for the
forthcoming future in order to be able
to think about though the wonders are
the universe and what the journey that
these seeds have taken and where that
leads to in the future are you itching
to get back into space I think every
astronaut is it tuned to get back to
space that's what we train so hard for
but more so than that the next five
years in space travel is going to be
incredibly exciting we've got two new
commercial space vehicles this year that
will fly to the International Space
Station that SpaceX and Boeing and we've
got a new Artemis project with NASA
which the European Space Agency is
heavily involved in which is looking
going beyond low-earth orbit once again
returning to the moon's orbit and
eventually landing on the surface of the
Moon so there's an awful lot happening
in space and it's a great time to be an
astronaut it's a great time to be
involved in the space program anywhere
the tennis world is used to its fair
share of comebacks from Roger Federer to
Selena
now comply stirrers is prepared for her
second new year decade after last put in
the sport
[Music]
the Belgian first retired aged 23 to
start a family before returning to
become world number one I'm speaking to
our sports correspondent Martha Kellner
Buster says at the age of 36 she can
still compete with the world's best
players at this tennis academy on the
outskirts of three how do you feel out
on court compared to say when you're in
your late teens early twenties it's hard
to compare to how I felt when I was 21
years old I was I'm sure I was a lot
quicker I was a lot faster my eyesight
was better my reactions were quicker but
I do feel like I can still yeah do you
look at the likes of Serena Williams and
Venus Williams and moto Federer playing
in sort of their mid to late thirties
and Beyond and think you know what
tennis may be an older person's sport
right now um yeah I mean it looks like
it is I mean I think you know over the
years I think Venus to me has been
someone who have really looked up to and
just seeing what serena has done in the
last year's you know she had her baby
and has been incredible as well it's
there for a mom of three kids and I know
that's the the major role in your life
is there any guilt that you have for
coming back I think you lose a little
bit of the guilt as your kids get older
the more kids you have
I remember when Jada was little and I
had to go to practice and you know she
would be standing inside of our house
and I would come here and practice you
know for my tournaments and then she
would be crying at the at the class back
door and I feel so guilty and I would
think like what am i doing
and now it's a word that can still feel
taboo even in 2020 but it is the subject
of a brand-new podcast the happy vagina
aims to shine a light on woman's
personal experience in a sex gynecology
and what they're doing to look after
their health it's created and hosted by
Mika Simmons filmmaker and the founder
of the women's health charity and Lady
card and foundation we could join me now
in the studio along with actress you'll
recognize her from Vikings on the
History Channel
Georgia Hurst who is a guest in one of
the upcoming episodes of the podcast hi
ladies hello makers interesting isn't it
is 2020 people still shy away from
saying the word vagina let alone having
a conversation about anything to do with
it yeah they do
can I just first say congratulations on
your half of Aegina thank you very much
I'm sure it might not be happy in about
six months yeah there is some taboo
around it it's definitely changing I'm
really excited by the movement is going
on with with women being more open
everywhere but I mean I started the lady
garden Foundation and one of our kind of
the things that we were always always
saying is that people need to talk more
and then I realize that somehow other we
still weren't talking more we were all
saying we need to talk more we need to
share more we need to be more open and
use more of the vocabulary around
gynecology and reproduction and we
weren't so I thought a podcast would be
an amazing place to because it's so free
you can say whatever you want on a
podcast juju it's interesting I came to
the recording of the podcast that you
appear in it was in front of a live
audience and you come at this from a
very personal angle because you had HPV
and precancerous cells when you were in
your early 20s what was that like
because I'm imagining as a young woman
in her 20s
talking about women's health wasn't high
on your jet agenda yeah certainly it was
scary but liberating I have to just say
being part of the podcast was really
important because it really champions
are wonderfully sort of complicated
bodies I think especially in my episode
it the key was to look after them and
certainly when I found out I had
precancerous cells I was obviously
confused I was 22 years old I was fit
and healthy and unfortunately for me
you know the HPV had turned my cells
cancerous and luckily since I had them
removed it's completely like clear but
for a lot of people I think it's
something like 80% of people have the
HPV virus and don't know and their body
clears out of their system there's no
saying you know who's gonna be the
unlucky ones but I would just say listen
to your body if you feel anything
unusual or any kind of dodgy symptoms
you're never too young
together smear I think because if I had
been 25 my story would have been a
really different one
Mika the clues in the title happy vagina
you have a bit of fun with this as well
because you know to get people
comfortable talking about something that
they probably don't talk about that
often it's putting them at their ease
isn't it and finding a bit of common
ground and having a bit of a laugh
absolutely and the opening of each
podcast we have a quiz so I said how am
I gonna get people to use all the words
that they wouldn't want me use to talk
about things they wouldn't so I have a
quiz at the beginning which kind of
covers all the vocabulary we get it all
out of the way and then we go deeper and
we talk about really personal issues for
people difficult for a woman to start
her own business in Britain but it's
even more of a struggle for female
entrepreneurs in the poorest countries
around the world
so after balancing a successful legal
career with being a mom and a wife of
the Prime Minister Sharif lair launched
a multi-million pound campaign to give
those women those business women more
support we have done amazing work three
680 women entrepreneurs since January
2018 thrilled hello talk to me about
your campaign and what you've managed to
achieve so far well firstly as you said
business has a problem across the world
what's the problem we're not attracting
and we're not retaining women and as a
result of that the world economy is
suffering of research by BCG showed that
we could add another five trillion
dollars to the world economy if women
were given equal access to business as
men so we want to help women redefine
the future in 2020 it's time we change
that dynamic so for the last 10 years my
foundation has been working with women
entrepreneurs in low middle-income
countries as you say some of the poorest
countries in the world but also some of
the countries that are on the brink of
becoming more successful and they will
become more successful even more
successful if they had women involved in
their economy it's partly to do with the
fact the world of work is designed for
men and it doesn't work for women when
they're balancing work and family life
and many of them therefore are
redefining their future by setting up
their own businesses 80% of the women in
the labour leadership contest while 80%
of the candidates are women one man for
women we've had to conservatives program
its tyr's who were women so far I know
well that is that that is a shame isn't
it but excellent that we've actually
even had some women Prime Minister's I
obviously would like to see more but as
you say it has to be the right
candidates I think that we are going to
see in the next few weeks whether the
Labour Party is going to turn out and
talk to the electorate as opposed to
talking to you
now a new sky drama is exploring how
Britain's top politicians and experts
still with an impending national
disaster and the collapse of society
while the carlyle stars by minister rust
into crisis when the nation is plunged
into darkness he spoke to Lisa cotton
now will now speak for the palace so
that emergency can authorize the
necessary powers under the 2004 civil
contingencies act this is now a national
emergency
and Cobra will remain an active
transcription what's going to be
different and for people as less this
human thing you know that the you will
see the Prime Minister other politicians
within his cabinet as real people as
human beings you know and I said we tend
to kind of not see politicians like that
sometimes you know quite rightly we
don't see politicians like that well now
we will be shooting it was with Theresa
May was wasn't Perla at that point and
she was going back and forward to say
Brussels this whole brexit business you
know and you could see you know that she
was she was aging by the day you know
and because I was I don't know how I
felt about her had there not been
planned that that's part but because I
was I was looking at this thinking she's
just a person you know she's really just
a person at the end of the day but um
you see someone cannot fall apart
without front your eyes I thought was
quite sad you've been in Canada for
quite a long time now and you're in some
ways a bit of an outsider looking it has
been interesting for me because I I've
been I've been away for the best part of
ten years now
someone told me ten years ago
you know projected what was going to be
happening this is you're crazy you know
even though the people that are in power
know you didn't see him really sad to
see what's been happening you know from
a farm seen her divisive has been
divisive the politics has become and to
see how people of even people within the
same family fighting about this thing
this all brexit thing is really gonna
torn us apart as a nation but also we
have it in Scotland as well it was very
very close to vote work with independent
since column of that referendum and the
effects that are still ongoing
you can reluctant to talk about it and
I'm reluctant to talk about it as well
to be honest with you because you come
down once a day the other you're gonna
get some sorts of abuse from one same
now how are you doing on your new year's
resolutions be honest because it when it
comes to those resolutions new research
shows that nearly 1/5 of us make and
break the same resolution each and every
year and with more than half of us
saying health goals are the ones that
are hardest to keep why is it so easy to
throw in the towel or one man who knows
all about dedication and resilience and
getting up and going again and again and
again is my next guest British ski
jumper at Michael Edwards better known
as Eddie the Eagle hello I thought it
went sailing all the time no you dig in
and you get on with it and you never
give up so much strength yeah you're the
perfect person to talk about this and
say why are it's so good at just
throwing in a towel and giving up I
think it's merely to do with modern
living
everybody wants instant results because
everything is instant nowadays and so if
they don't feel a health benefit or they
don't lose enough weight instantly they
give up and I think they should just
just stick with it maybe if they sort of
lower the goal a little bit sometimes
they set goals too big I'm gonna lose 10
stone this year and I think well initial
50 stone to start with you're not going
to lose 10 stone in here but if you lose
one pound a week one pound in weight
which is not difficult and then at the
end of the year that's 52 pounds that's
like four and a half stone so that's a
bit easier so break it down my Ami's
have a big long-term goal but make sure
you have little steps as well we've made
ski jumping I started on the little
jumps worked my way up to the big ones
and that's the same sort of ethos really
think about it differently when I told
people what I wanted to do they were
great they helped me with food they let
me sleep in their places they drove me
from jump to jump because I didn't know
where they were so having a support
network was vital it was always a good
idea to have a positive resolution
rather than a negative one I know giving
up the booze cigarettes and eating
better are all positive aims but you're
depriving yourself for something so I
always think if I'm going to do a
resolution I want to add something
whether it's just I'm going to try and
learn a language which is one that comes
up every year I never do it but I feel
like I'm adding I do a little bit of it
or I go and travel somewhere or I'm
gonna reconnect with friends doing
something positive I think yeah I think
if you have a series of resolutions I
think that helps you might have a
negative one but those are positive ones
as well and for
it's yeah I want to travel more I want
to ski more I'm gonna dance more I want
to do things and do exciting things
that's what I put in my reservation
[Applause]
you